vrai youssou ndour accumule les succès
le chanteur sénégalais a composé l'hymne
de la coupe du monde de football cette
année il a été primé aux victoires de la
musique et sa tournée en france est
aussi une réussite
stéphane dumas et christian de carnets
sont allés avec cet artiste engagée en
afrique du sud
à soweto où a été tourné le dernier clip
de son album sur la route de soweto
youssou ndour constate qu'en six ans
rien n'a changé un taux de criminalité
record
70 % de chômage l'apartheid a certes été
officiellement aboli aps
mais malgré les décisions politiques la
vie quotidienne est restée la même
la plupart des enfants ne vont pas à
l'école des écoles qu en tant
qu'ambassadeur 2007
youssou ndour et voudrait construire
maintenant ce peuple a besoin beaucoup
de temps pour l'éducation puisse être
vraiment une base de fond et il ya
certainement aussi beaucoup d'autres
choses qui n'ont pas été prises en
compte dès le départ donc ils vont
prendre encore du temps pour que
vraiment l'apartheid finissent à 100%
cette chanson évoque le village
traditionnel africain qui doit
impérativement s'ouvrir au monde et pour
ses fans
youssou ndour c'est le lien entre les
cultures africaines et occidentales
mesplède en tant que noir c'est
important pour moi de connaître les
autres cultures et de savoir ce que les
autres cultures pan de la situation ici
en afrique du sud est du ier de soweto
au quartier branché de johannesburg
partout où il va il s'implique dans la
vie locale chez lui au sénégal grâce à
la musique qu'il a créé plus de 200
emplois il voudrait faire la même chose
en afrique du sud
en produisant des artistes locaux ont
fait du site est important symbolisait
beaucoup de choses beaucoup au moins
musicalement je passe aussi ce peuple a
vécu tellement de choses difficiles dans
l'éducation dans plein de choses comme
ça donc on ne partage vraiment donc
quand celui-là je ressens beaucoup de
choses
partager c'est la base de son action il
demande donc l'effacement de la dette
des pays du tiers-monde
porte parole de l'afrique qui souffrent
youssou ndour continue d'avancer
modestement sur la voie qu'il s'est
tracée à mi chemin entre musique et
politique